[Applause]
this is cancellation corner I don't know
you but that outfit tells me you got a
Blog that I'm worried about
reading end my career is this how white
women feel when they see black dudes on
the same side of the street cuz I saw
her yall saw I saw her and I was like
nope not doing that okay let's be
careful around Eat Pray Love let's not
do that I'm sure you love India hope you
continue to love Indians after this show
are you with him or you alone you're
with him okay thank God all right cuz if
you came alone I would feel like like
you know what I mean you're like
Espionage of some kind where do you work
I'm hairy you're hair stylist oh okay
that's way better hair stylist you have
to be stylist so that explains that but
when I saw the kind of Indian Shaw I
thought you were one of you know the
armpit hair
types and I don't have a problem with
them they just tend to have a problem
with me so that's that's all I was
saying